i think the big question that most of us
want to know is are we at war with
france
well we're not and uh the reality is
that over the last nine months or so
we've actually licensed
close to 1700 eu vessels nearly 750 of
those have been french vessels and what
we're talking about here is a very small
proportion of vessels that the french
put forward to be licensed but the truth
is they just don't have a track record
of uh fishing in the areas where they
needed to be in order to qualify for one
so 98 of the vessels were given a
license much earlier this year even in
jersey they've now issued over 160
licenses to french vessels but there
will always be a small proportion that
don't qualify and that's what we're
talking about here so what is it you're
going to do then to ease the tensions at
the moment that we're seeing
well look we think that the um the the
comments that have been made by france
on this are you know completely
disproportionate they're unacceptable
that the things that they are suggesting
doing which is basically
uh start to be difficult at the borders
and close ports and so on you know this
is um a clear breach not only of the the
trade and cooperation agreement that
we've got with them you know but also of
of eu law the official control regime
and so we don't really think it's
justified at all because this is a very
small number of vessels that just don't
qualify under the terms of the agreement
that was reached and so what we're you
know asking france to do is obviously uh
try to calm this down and and remove
these threats that they're not
acceptable so what you've said is that
the threats are not acceptable another
thing you've also said is that what
you're going to do is um make sure that
they're met with a
proportionate um level of um you know
consequence basically if those threats
are carried out can you just explain to
us what that looks like from your point
of view well the first thing is um as
the uk the way that we approach these
things in the way that you you should is
we will be uh talking to the european
commission in fact i spoke to the
commissioner two days ago when these um
these threats were first made because
the european commission has got a a role
and a responsibility to make sure its
member states including france abide by
the law and abide by the terms of the
agreement that was reached we've also
summoned the the french ambassador liz
trust the foreign secretary is going to
raise these issues with her and ask her
to explain and give an account of what
they intend to do we don't know what
they'll do they say they wouldn't
introduce these measures until tuesday
probably at the earliest so we will see
what they do but obviously if they do
bring this into place well two can play
at that game and uh you know we
obviously you know reserve the ability
to be able to respond in a proportionate
way let me just pick you up on that
point um the french ambassador being
summoned um what's happened he was
summoned last night what's come of it um
well the the normal uh protocol on this
is um you know i would expect at some
point over the next
day or so that the ambassador would
would meet the foreign secretary that is
um you know that is generally what
happens it's also possible that the
prime minister will have an opportunity
to to meet president macron obviously
because they'll both be
gathering getting ready for for cop 26.
um you know we we want to defuse this uh
this issue but the truth is
we've not done anything wrong we've
abided by the terms of the uh trade
incorporation agreement and nearly 1700
eu vessels have been licensed to fish in
our waters we've granted them very
generous access there's a small
percentage just two percent of the
applicants
who don't qualify and that's what we're
talking about here and so the reaction
that france have come up with is really
totally disproportionate now we're just
hearing that the french agricultural
minister has just been speaking on
french tv saying that there's been no
progress at all between the uk and
france why is he saying that clearly
nothing is happening nothing is going
forward
well um what's happening is that we've
applied the terms of the trade
incorporation agreement and so
jersey um decided on monday uh that they
uh the approach that they would take
they communicated that to france uh and
the commission on tuesday um that was
announced um uh yesterday in the end um
but there were you know as i said around
163 vessels
that had access to jersey waters that
were entitled to a uh license they've
granted those licenses some of them on
an interim basis until january while
more evidence is gathered but there are
55 french vessels that had applied for
access to jersey waters but couldn't
demonstrate a track record during the
reference period so they just hadn't
been accessing jersey waters it might be
understandable they'd like the option to
at some point in the future but that's
not what was agreed and all parties
understood what was agreed through that
trade and cooperation agreement i mean
from what you've said france's
government claims that its country's
fishermen lack half the licenses that
they require to fish in british waters
and they're owned they owed them after
brexit
is that true no that's simply not true
um why are they saying that then well um
they've been granted as i said close to
750 licenses
what we're talking about here is
around 55 licenses in the context of
jersey that haven't been issued and
haven't been granted but that's because
they don't qualify so they're not
entitled to those licenses that's why
they've not been granted one but what we
have done it's been very generous so far
jersey
offered interim licenses to those
vessels while they
gathered the data so
they've been very reasonable and
pragmatic they didn't really need to do
that there was no obligation on them but
they've been quite generous in their
approach
here in the the uk for access to our
insure waters we've also worked very
closely with the commission um and with
the french to try and help them
understand the data that they need to
offer we've even
used data that we have to try to
understand better individual
applications that have been put forward
so we've been
entirely reasonable throughout all this
um we've issued licenses as soon as
we've been able to and as i said to
around 1 700 eu vessels overall let's
pick up on that word you said that
reasonable i think the french looking at
deals like the orcas agreement may think
that the uk has been a reasonable do you
think that tensions from that is
playing a part here
well look it shouldn't because even even
that agreement that was about um uh
three big allies uh the us the uk and
australia you know working uh together
on a um you know defense and cooperation
project focus specifically around around
the the pacific so um you know again i
know the french had some issues uh with
that um but it's really not sensible to
say that major allies like the the uk
and us and australia shouldn't be able
to come to such agreements how much of
this would you say is political
grandstand because obviously macron has
elections coming up next year
yeah well look um there are elections
coming up in france um i've seen
suggestions that that might be a factor
but you know we have to to deal with
what we're we're faced with here which
is really france threatening some
actions that are completely
disproportionate um not acceptable would
be a breach of the agreement that we
have with them and uh um that's why
we're we're going to be raising that
with their ambassador and raising it
with the commission
so one of the things that you've
obviously talked about you talked about
how you want to deal with this and the
measures that you hope to put in place
to deal with this but what if france
doesn't actually take on what you're
saying what then what happens if
relations and tensions completely break
down
well look we'll obviously be um dealing
with the european commission and it's
important to to note that because you
know france is an eu member so the
european commission represent them on
these matters we'll be dealing with the
european commission on this um um
pointing out to them and explaining that
we've issued now um 1 700 licenses
that's 98 of all the applicants
explaining to them and sharing with them
the data so that they can understand
that that remaining two percent
you know just didn't qualify under the
terms of the agreement i think the
commission will understand that and
obviously then you know it's for the
commission to
to try to manage um you know raise
relations with france and explain that
uh to france this doesn't bode very well
does it for johnson and macron when they
meet at cop 26
in just a few days time
well look in international relations um
there are countries that we you will
sometimes have differences with on
individual issues but i think the the
whole world uh will want to be coming
together to address the big challenge of
climate change and so there are going to
be ministers there from uh from china
from uh russia many other countries
around the world who were seeking to to
build uh agreements with um and i think
when it comes to climate change
everybody recognizes that whatever
differences we might have on other
aspects of uh international policy or
domestic policy or fishing policy we all
put that to one side in order to address
this really big challenge of climate
change okay let's talk about insulate
britain because the high court order
against them is clearly not working
they're still ignoring the injunction
and they're stopping people from going
about their day-to-day lives and
activities so what is it that you're
going to do to stop them from what
they're doing well the home secretary
announced a few weeks ago
some
some plans to strengthen the law in this
area so that we can
strengthen the penalties and give the
police more early intervention powers in
cases like this but at the moment there
is that
injunction in place
um if they're in breach of that uh
injunction then they're in contempt of
court and the police do have the ability
therefore to
you know to arrest them and take action
but they're ignoring the injunction it's
not having any effect on them whatsoever
well and if people ignore an injunction
then they are at that point in content
of court so
the injunction is is there for a purpose
which is to give the police the ability
to uh to make arrests and um and
and then move to you know contempt of
court proceedings for those who are in
breach of the injunction let's talk
about um go back to cop 26 as well boris
johnson has said this week that is touch
and go
um if it's successful and do you feel
the same does this week's budget really
help at all
well look um
these uh events because they are big
multilateral events with many countries
it is often difficult to to get progress
we've been working incredibly hard
though
on our agenda which is getting more
countries to commit to net zero by the
middle of the century getting
commitments on decarbonizing uh
transport and particularly
electrification of cars and in my case
working quite hard on a package around
forests uh mobilizing finance and
getting agreement on uh you know
reducing and and halting the the net
loss of forests around the world so
i'm i'm optimistic about uh these
agendas but always obviously when we're
in the final days and the build-up to it
uh you do get uh you know
nervous about whether you'll get things
over the line certain agreements over
the line there's more to be done at the
actual summit itself um i'm optimistic
um but it is as the prime minister said
touch and go
george eastern's environment secretary
thank you very much indeed for your time
please